I think design from what I understand
comes a lot from the place of empathy
and understanding what the end user
needs are which is very similar in the
sense from what we do in social services
so there's a lot of synergy already in
that
the aim of this project was to design
change basically to design the change of
mindset we've come to recognize the fact
that caregivers are a blind spot for
most health and care systems around the
world if you have a caregiver that is
empower it feels confident and has the
skills to give care you can impact the
clinical outcome of a patient or other
clients so the design thinking
methodology starts by understanding of
people and we use design ethnography to
go out and spend time with people in
their everyday life so in this project
it was about going out and spending time
with caregivers we're zooming out to
understand their journeys as a whole
their life as a whole and to understand
their experiences over time this really
helped us to convey the experiences of
caregivers conveyed to the group of
people that are actually making this
change in the end the insight based
thinking helped it to be more than a
book because it f is a suite of products
that it helps at different levels from
the conceptual level in terms of being
able to understand some of the insights
in their to their films as well that
actually is very visual and helps to the
hook has to fit where there are range of
tools that would help a caregiver
understand their caregiving journey the
persona the emotions perhaps in terms of
how the topologies are as a caregiver
it's a moment for designers future
designers to to become very conscious
about the use of their skills we have a
responsibility and there is a potential
to
to social change and now is a moment for
this
[Music]